hello everybody I hope they are good
yesterday was a big day for the markets
we had CPI but you can see that the
volatility in the chart was crazy
and as I always tell you guys don't
trade news announcements don't gamble
because you don't know what the results
are going to be that almost impossible
to predict you have there
JP Morgan Bank of America all the top
Banks trying to predict and their
predictions don't match
you mean you can be right you can be
wrong that's gambling
okay so I always wait at least 30
minutes or 45 minutes to start trading
okay because that is always some
imbalances after data comes out because
usually price reacts very aggressively
in this case the results were slightly
better than expected I mean core CPI is
still very sticky but the the CPI
became uh four or nine percent and they
were expecting five percent so still
consider the one percent is not much but
you can see the inflation it's going
lower so that was kind of
bullish for the market and the first
reaction was to go up but then they left
all this liquid people here if we Mark
in our chart is this blue box so we know
the price is going to come back to it
because that's what they usually do
during fomc and CPI data or run Farm
payrolls they leave liquidity pools
behind that they come back to in the
future
so at that moment we were waiting for
some kind of signal to go short and we
were lucky to get something quite
obvious and it is all this week's to the
upside but price no progressing any
further you know it's telling me that
they are building their shorts okay and
the market maker is trapping breakout
Traders because with every single week
this week's
they are making the the breakout trailer
to go long because they are making them
think I didn't want to sift up this Zone
and go higher so that's what the retail
Trader thinks
and then we'll have a different story
what can make it is doing here is
building their shorts
in resistance because if you check this
for our time frame
that's your 50 EMA
all right so that's your Confluence now
we'll go back to the one hour time frame
I was looking to cut a sword in this
Orange Box
and the only problem is that I close the
short too early because I close my short
at the 1 hour 50ma because I was you
know worried that we're gonna see maybe
something like this push up retrace to
the 150ma and continue a continuation so
what I did was to close my short in the
water 50 maybe because sometimes it's
true that you can see in the 50ma as
strong production I mean so I closed my
entire shot here mistake because price
dumped under one thousand dollars but
anyway it's still a safe trade to take I
thought it was a high prudent trade it
was and it was a good profit I didn't
because this is um around 400 moved you
know that's that's a good move for me
now if you look at the chart what you
can say is that they left a week behind
that they haven't come back to it yet
all right so price is in my opinion
gonna come to this song at some point
now what they did here and this is what
I what I went into another short was a
retreats to the 50ma in the one hour
time frame I opened a short here
that I had to close here so it was
almost breaking even because the the one
hour candle closed above the 50ma says
okay I'm gonna close this and see what
happens then I saw that price you know
was coming again Lower and and the same
point I opened a short again so now I'm
short and they're waiting because I'm
thinking well when I see this week
getting filled I mean it's possible that
we still have another retest of the of
the 50ma okay maybe you can do something
like this but I think price will
eventually come back to this week that's
what I'm anticipating Bitcoin to do
um or Target would be 27
137 and 26
777 but if you were to have a capital
there is something that is concerning
let's go there worry hablo Capital let's
go to the one month time frame this is
the time frame that I shared a screen
suggested in Twitter uh you can see
something very interesting here let's
focus on this Zone okay
you can see guys that there is a lot of
Liquidations in the Sun at 26 400 all
right and you can see that we knew that
there was liquidations here when we were
all in 29 029k so we were saying okay
price can go either to this one here
that is 30 between thirty thousand three
hundred and thirty one thousand three
hundred or
it can go all the way to 26 000.
then we have this week so we're
anticipating 27 200 to get retraced and
price did so all right but now you can
see that yesterday we have this week
that went all the way to 26 700.
but they haven't come to twenty six
thousand four hundred
here it is where you have to use some
logic all right and you have to think
okay so they haven't hit this
reputations
for three hundred dollars difference
that we knew that they existed and they
were therefore qual some time I mean we
knew that they were there at least for a
one week ago okay so this is a zone that
uh it's an important Zone in the chart
now why they haven't hit these locations
why they have said A week in 26 700 and
then they push price all the way to 27
800.
I've seen these moves before happening
quite often and what I can tell you of
course no Financial advice this is this
is only what I think well usually what
we see
I mean if they haven't hit these
liquidation just straight away and they
were so close to them and then they
bounced this is usually a rune for
liquidity all right this pushes a room
for liquidity why because if they push
price from here
a lot of Traders are gonna go long
because they're gonna be calling for a
v-shape formation and we're gonna go all
the way to 30k again right so if Traders
go along here
where are they gonna place the rest stop
losses below their weak and eyes this
soon 26 400 also
high level traders that go times 50
times 100 leverage that the stop losses
are going to be in The Sun Also so you
can see that in this Zone really what is
happening is that they have added a lot
of liquidity
all right although if High block can do
that let me check we had here 19 billion
dollars of liquidations that's what they
estimate and now it says 21 billion and
a half so yes they found it liquidity
and I think that's accurate I think it's
quite obvious that there is more
liquidity here now that there was in the
past because with these bounds I'm sure
many Traders are positioned in logs now
all right
so that takes you to the conclusion that
this might be a room for liquidity to
push price up from here to come back to
later on all right and then hit a lot
more liquidity more stop losses more
liquidations so this zone is going to be
more important and they're gonna be able
to come to this Zone in a more efficient
way because this is what they care about
they care about efficiency
all right I hope that was clear guys so
be careful if you are thinking to go
along from here
I think that if you see all these
liquidations here this should be a red
flag for opening Longs at this moment
all right I hope that's clear guys
let me introduce you this chart in life
this is the order book you have probably
seen me using this in Twitter too but I
think it can be a good add-on to show it
in the video too this is basically our
order book in our way of a hit map that
tells you where the orders are this
includes limit orders buy and sell limit
orders also stop losses and liquidations
because stop losses and liquidations are
also limit orders all right so in here
you cannot instinct or a liquidation or
establos is from a buy or limit order
but you can see where the liquidity is
because really all those things are
liquidity all right and I mean if you
notice
twenty seven thousand you know it's a
round number we expecting that zone to
be quite of liquidity the same as you
can see that around 28 000 there is also
some obviously there is some more up 27
000 because work closer to it and we
have also been there and if you notice
twenty six thousand eight hundred all
right that's around the week because the
week is at twenty six thousand seven
hundred seventy seven I think it is
so that's basically telling you that
there is quite a lot of liquidity in the
week a 26 000 800. so you know I I don't
trade based on this uh but I actually
use it as Confluence because it tells
you where the liquidity is in this case
you know it's good to see some kind of
Confluence to the idea that I mean the
the weekly strategy doesn't need much
confidence but sometimes it's good to
see okay there is a liquidity pool let's
see if there is really liquidity there
and you can see that it is and you see
okay I'm feeling comfortable with IV I'm
confident
that price is going to get that I mean
it doesn't have to boo you know it's
more likely to so keep an eye on the
week this is a little extra Confluence
so you can use 26 777.
so anyway guys be careful I might be
wrong but that's what I think okay after
watching the chart for so many hours and
using the high block for quite some time
I'm saying how price usually reacts I
would tell you guys I would suggest you
to be careful here all right because
that looks to me this bouncier to me
okay
that looks like a rune for liquidity in
my opinion to gather more liquidity in
this Zone over here so I think price
will eventually come down to the Zone I
don't know if that's going to happen
today or tomorrow but I think we're
probably gonna see
these prices again all right so anyway
guys thank you so much for watching I
hope this video was useful for you and
you learned something new
let me know what you think in the
comments
thank you so much and I'll see you soon